lest you are having trouble actually
visualizing what's going on
okay that's cloud of the problem they're
both the same distance from the road and
B yeah hey B both hanging in now you're
looking to minimize the distance between
these two guys that distance there okay
now the first thing it is well obviously
the distance is going to be least when
they get to the origin okay but the
problem with that is right so I've got
one guy going a clear DK's an hour okay
and the other one traveling faster so
therefore they'll both pass the origin
but not at the same time right so being
that Justin being that you're gonna have
you know the passenger time this one B
right he's gonna get in closer right so
just imagine what's gonna happen off the
Seine how long okay
after an hour for a hundred right that's
where they're starting he's gonna be
here at say sixty kilometers from the
intersection all right whereas this one
will be at 70 so this is what you've got
joining them short up five another hour
you have to say 20 but he's still stuck
up at 40 kilometers away right so you're
getting is gradient changing all right
now if I go another hour where will they
be okay this one's actually gonna go all
the way across the other side right so
to be consistent I'll call that minus 20
this one is still up above right he's
gonna be a 10 so I've still got this
distance in between them it looks like
it's less but it starts to get worse
right
this guy's gonna pass the intersection
he's gonna be at minus 20 okay and this
guy off he goes I guess he'll be at
minus 60 at this point right so you can
see it started to get worse so therefore
I'm gonna have some kind of position in
between here where I'm at the sweet spot
yeah so fast
all right now that's trying to
understand what's going on if you put
together a simplified diagram
there's my intersection okay he is a and
usually we start off when we assign some
pronumerals right now a very
common-sense way to do this is say well
horizontal distance you'd call that X
right vertical distance you call it Y so
then you start to think about well how
am I going to get rid off one of these
very much right this is the distance
it's called a date yeah has anyone
spotted already what's the problem with
a signing parameters like that any ideas
there's a significant problem X&Y right
usually with two variables I ought to be
able to do something I'd say relate area
or greeting or something like that which
will allow me to get one in terms of the
other right now that assumes there's a
relationship between the two the problem
here is there is no relationship between
the two right this guy's heading in a
one speed this guy's heading in another
they're independent of each other okay
it's not like one's dragging the other
along okay so what you're actually going
to need to do is introduce something
which we're gonna deal with as a whole
topic later on I talked about this a
couple of days ago find the parametric's
we're gonna introduce a new printer rule
a parameter okay
now instead of x and y let's think about
what these things are doing right where
do they start at they begin they both
start hundred away okay so I'm gonna
call let's start with this horizontal
one a little starting position 100 now
as time progresses this distance gets
short off right what rate does it get
shorter at well the one I'm doing it 40
points out so it's getting smaller so
I'm gonna take a subtraction right and
for every hour
it gets 40 smaller right so it's called
T the time in
that makes sense so what I'm thinking
about is all of this in terms of a third
iron right this time variable so now you
can think about what this one up here
will be right it's also going to start
off at 100 but it's not gonna be able to
my sweetie it'll be minus 30 right okay
now there's my clue I want you to go
back to the drawing board and see if you
can count with an equation for D that
you can differentiate okay okay if you
can it's time to go